what if a better definition of selflove
would be holding yourself to a higher
standard than anybody else's yes what if
you are your own biggest champion and
then what if having good friends that
care about you are people who believe in
you more than they pity you so that when
things get hard they don't pat you on
the shoulder Lex won't mind me telling
the story I think maybe the Ukraine war
had just started out he was trying to
keep an ear on that and maybe he's going
to go out and speak to Putin or somebody
else he's trying to build robots and
then he's trying to do his podcast and
he's doing all of these different things
and he was talking about how he was
lamenting juggling all of these plates
to some of his friends a lot of his
friends kind of patted him on the
shoulder and said oh man you work so
much already you should go easier on
yourself he turned and looked at me and
he went I wish people would stop saying
that I wish that they would say yeah
this is tough but you're tougher for
someone who seeks in their friends
people who believe in them more than
they pity them self love is holding
yourself to a higher standard than
anybody else does that is just such a a
powerful idea functionally much more
useful as well